[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story tonight the British cruise
missiles being delivered to Ukraine the
most powerful weapon yet to help defeat
Russia's invasion
as Ukraine's forces prepare for their
counter-assault Russia warns the UK's
decision will require an answer from its
military also tonight
Sky News learns that Sue gray who
investigated Downing Street parties
before leaving to work for Labor's
leader had personal contact with the
party Gates inquiries labor chair
betting the house on the bank of
England's reputation the criticism of
its predictions as it raises interest
rates again you keep getting it wrong I
mean is is the simple truth here that
basically the bank isn't very good at
forecasting
I don't agree with that
plus we report from Texas where Donald
Trump's restrictions on migrant border
crossings are about to expire
look no hands on board the UK's first
self-driving bus taking passengers from
next week
and we'll be taking a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30 tonight
[Music]
hi there very good evening to you the
most powerful weapons yet provided to
Ukraine by the UK are already in the
country tonight cruise missiles which
could strike at Russian Depots and
command posts deep inside occupied land
the defense secretary said the
government was providing them because
Ukraine had the right to defend itself
Russia though warned it had a very
negative attitude to the deployment it
comes ahead of an expected
counter-offensive by Ukrainian forces
and will be live in the country in a
moment first though our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes reports
breaking down a new barrier when it
comes to arming Ukraine the UK has
donated long-range missiles in defiance
of concern about Russia's response this
old promotion video giving a sense of
the weapons impact the use of Storm
Shadow will allow Ukraine to push back
Russian forces based within Ukrainian
Sovereign territory the defense
secretary told MPS the UK's modern
missiles are being fitted to Ukraine's
old aircraft a difficult and
time-consuming task I'm not going to
comment on when these we expect these to
be used but nevertheless they have yet
to be tested and and we will soon find
out Storm Shadow is a Precision guided
cruise missile
from the air
Warhead weighing up to a thousand pounds
is five meters in length and can hit a
Target at a range of more than 155 miles
the weapon is powerful enough to punch
through reinforced concrete and could be
used to hit underground bunkers command
headquarters and weapon supplies
a Ukrainian military Source said to me
this decision by the UK could be a game
changer he said the Russians had learned
to move their weapon stores and command
posts out of the range of the Rockets
the ukrainians have but these new
missiles will give Ukraine the ability
to strike much deeper into russian-held
territory even in theory as far as the
bridge that connects the captured
Crimean Peninsula with Russia
the British move prompted a menacing
message from Moscow
at uh
on the front line though the UK's
missiles will be a big boost for Ukraine
as the fighting grinds on ahead of an
expected counter-offensive officials
hope other allies will follow suit
this is not the first time when UK takes
a lead on life or death decisions for
Ukraine and then the rest follows we
have seen it since the beginning of the
full-scale invasion the UK has fired
Storm Shadow missiles multiple times
against its enemies these typhoon Jets
were preparing to hit Islamic State
Targets in the Middle East
attaching the weapons to Ukrainian
aircraft is a whole new level of risk
but also potentially reward
debraham Sky News
[Applause]
well our International correspondent
Alex Rossi is in Ukraine tonight we can
speak to him now and Alex how close do
you think the ukrainians are now to
having the military hard way that they
think they need to launch this
counter-offensive
I think the training the hardware that
they needed is all coming together it is
very close now how imminent exactly is
unclear we've been hearing an interview
from president zielinski where he has
said they're not quite ready yet they're
still waiting for armored vehicles
because although the troops are trained
and ready to go they fear that they'd
lose people they wouldn't have to lose
if they just waited a bit longer so that
is something that they can't really
countenance having said that it may be
misdirection it may be faint it's not
just the physical Battlefield that is
being contested the information space is
also being contested as well certainly
on Russian telegram channels they are
reporting they claim that the
counter-offensive has already started
now troops that we're speaking to along
the line of contact which stretches for
hundreds of miles they are saying that
the fighting has become more intense
particularly around the city of back
move people will remember that a symbol
really of the hell and horror of this
war one Brigade there told us that one
of their operations they managed to take
back about three square miles of land
now whether or not they can hold that we
don't know it may be that what we are
seeing at the moment are just shaping
operations before the main push that is
still to come but the ukrainians know
that they do need to get this right they
fear the leadership here that if they
don't have some kind of success
political support in the west may be
more difficult to sustain going forwards
okay Alex for now thank you very much
Sky News has learned that the senior
civil servant who investigated lockdown
parties in Downing Street had personal
contact with the labor chair of the
committee investigating Boris Johnson
sugoi was later appointed so Kia
stalma's new Chief of Staff though she
hasn't yet been able to take up the post
our political correspondent Joe Pike
wrote that story tonight and he joins us
now what more have you learned Joe
well Emma what is interesting about this
is it concerns two prominent women
who've LED different party gate related
inquiries first of all as you say
Harriet Harman veteran labor MP who's
the current chair of the ongoing a
parliamentary inquiry into the Boris
Johnson misled MPS uh over party gate
the second individual is Sue Greg he
said the senior civil servant who wrote
the internal government report into what
had happened in number 10 and in the
cabin office as you say now uh planning
to take a job with labor and Kirsten Sky
News can reveal the two individuals last
year after Sue Gray's report came out in
the early stages of the Parliamentary
inquiry were in a direct personal
contact One Source remembers Harriet
Harman saying I just speak to sue making
it clear that the contact seemingly was
regular and reasonably close now why
does this matter some would argue of
course that these two individuals
investigating similar things would talk
what it would be strange as they hand
talk that's certainly implication from
privileges committee you've released
this statement to Sky News tonight it
was they say the duty of the chair to
make contact with anyone including Sue
gray who might be able to indicate
potential Witnesses the only evidence
the committee will rely on is that which
is separately and independently verified
by the relevant witness the Privileges
committee is not rely on evidence
gathered by Sue gray the other opinion
of course including from allies of Boris
Johnson is that there is potentially a
significant a conflict of interest and
questions for Harriet Harman to answer
that's certainly the view of the former
cabinet minister Jacob riesmock
as this is all about strict accuracy and
whether things are misleading or not
misleading the chairman had a duty to
the committee to be very very strictly
and straightforwardly accurate and the
question has to be asked did she achieve
this
we should stress there is no suggestion
that Harriet Harman was aware that labor
was trying to recruit Sue gray before as
Connie's broke the story and also no
suggestion that Sue gray spoke to
Harriet Harman after first being
approached by the labor party in
kierstanbus but certainly potentially
have a questions to answer and of course
that privileges Committee in the
building behind me does still continue
waiting to hit their final report
whether they believe Boris Johnson has
misled Parliament and indeed if there
will be a punishment if he has
okay Joe for now thank you
millions of mortgage holders still face
the worst of rising interest rates the
bank of England's Governor worn today
because so many people remain on their
original fixed deals around two-thirds
of the pain is still to be felt Andrew
Bailey was speaking after the bank
raised interest rates to four and a half
percent it also raised its forecast of
UK growth there are though questions
over the bank's predictions as our
economics editor Ed Conway reports
when the world
about a mess there's plenty of Miss with
the economy right now but there's always
solace in music
they're setting up for the night at the
Phoenix Arts Club in London Soho but
even here the cost of living crisis is
hard to escape the costs are just rising
and Rising we work with several
suppliers across food and beverage
across electricity gas all of the
standard utilities that everyone pays
really but add a zero or a couple of
zeros to that and that's what it looks
like for a small business it's quite
scary actually and for many households
especially those with mortgages
especially those about to refix their
loans it is scary at the bank which has
raised rates again to 4.5 percent says
there's more pain to come we know that
by the end of this year there will be a
lot more mortgages that will reset
because fixed rate says come in for
millions of households and so we yeah
but we fact and we factored that in so
how much of the pain have we had so far
on that and how much has yet to come in
terms of resetting an adjustments it's
probably normal about a third but just
in terms of what her families can expect
so there is still two-thirds of the kind
of interest rate related pain yet to
come there's quite a large portion of
mortgages yet to reset that pain that
monetary squeeze is what mortgage
brokers around the country are now
having to help deliver it's not easy it
can be more stressful the pressure on
people to make quick decisions is hard
any more rate increases are going to be
quite
um hard to manage for a lot of
households in the UK and not only the
mortgages go in or obviously the bills
have gone up with that as well still
there was some good news from the bank
now surprising as it might sound given
the economic climate the bank has just
delivered the biggest upgrade to their
economic growth forecast that they have
ever seen the issue is they are starting
from such a miserable place that where
they are now is basically just about
flatlining the deeper issue though for
this institution is they've got so many
of their forecasts wrong in the past
that people are asking whether they can
actually rely on them at all
the governor denies there's a
credibility problem you keep getting it
wrong I mean is is the simple truth here
that basically the bank isn't very good
at forecasting
I don't agree with that you know we're
experiencing huge external shocks those
external shocks are frankly not
something you can forecast as such I
think about things like the war sort of
the war you can't forecast the public
was missing its forecast before the war
it was missing its forecasts before the
big the big right because there was
because there was an impact from 2021
there was an apart from covid on on what
we said called Supply chains regardless
of whether it was foreseeable the upshot
is we're all poorer says the bank a
tough message for those working hard to
make a living I feel poorer and it's not
like we have crazy expensive Lifestyles
anyway living costs have gone up
electricity gas
um like you say commute here is not
cheap at all I wish it was at some point
the economy will recover at some point
the news will get better but the latest
message from the bank is not quite yet
at Conway Sky News
on Supreme Court to order the release of
Imran Khan today saying his arrest was
unlawful the government's information
Minister though defended the former
prime minister's detention in an
interview with Sky News Imran Khan's
arrest two days ago led to protests and
violence across the country our
correspondent Cordelia Lynch is in
Islamabad and sent us this report
two days after his sudden arrest a
sudden turnaround for Imran Khan
the Supreme Court ruling it was illegal
and ordering his release but the
government can't see the problem do you
have faith in your Supreme Court as an
institution yes as individuals I have
questions are you suggesting that the
Supreme Court
as I said as I said Supreme Court as an
institution I'm not saying anything
because there are Judges I'm talking
about the individuals and the perception
when such orders are made I can after
the order it is my constitutional right
to analyze the order to discuss the
order to cite the order or to criticize
the order would you like to see Mr Khan
detained tomorrow
well it's it's up to the court as I said
the government is not part of this
arrest it's a national accountability uh
Bureau the court and the Islamabad High
Court let's see what Islamabad High
Court does tomorrow do you recognize
that there are peaceful people that
believe
the way that Imran Khan was arrested was
unlawful unacceptable a stain on the
country I did not see those peaceful
peoples on the streets in last three
days there are ways to arrest someone
tell me calmly tell me no no a person no
the person as I said a person who defies
law of the land uh and it if if it's not
Imran Khan if it's anybody I ask you the
question in your country also a conduct
of a person is as such what will the
police do
now the case goes to the high court
which must decide whether to Grant bail
so the stage is set for another dramatic
chapter in the Imran Khan story he has a
night at least to enjoy some freedom to
Rally his troops and to decide on his
next steps but we've seen how quickly
that freedom can be taken away
in this tense climate it's hard to
imagine any result will go unchallenged
Pakistan
the country's most controversial rail
franchise will reach the end of the line
later on this month with the government
taking trans penile Express back into
public control passengers that we spoke
to today were delighted but the
transport secretary warned that
nationalization isn't a silver bullet
offices correspondent Paul Kelso reports
finally transpennine Express passengers
have a cancellation they can celebrate
the end of the company's contract to run
Services across the North
rubbish they're just rubbish frustrated
I would say because oftentimes I get to
work late and that doesn't speak well of
me it's about a time but a lot of the
companies get nationalized this is
hopefully for me the first of many after
months of disruption Services between
Liverpool Manchester Leeds and Hull will
come under State Control when its
contract expires at the end of the month
to achieve the performance levels I
expect that passengers deserve and that
the northern economy needs it's clear
that both the contract and the
underlying relationships must be reset
transpennine Express owned by first
group has overseen huge disruption with
up to one in four Services canceled
every day to the frustration of
commuters and fury of Northern Mayors it
has been a catalog of misery people
moving house changing jobs losing
opportunities choosing a different
University because they know they can't
get there not taking up opportunities
for culture because they don't know if
they can get home missing funerals it
has been unacceptable transpennine is
the fourth franchise to come under State
Control reflecting the weakness of a
railway that's effectively been
government run since the pandemic
transpennine Express has a dreadful
record and it's come to symbolize The
Wider failings of the rail network that
sense of national infrastructure just
doesn't work as well as it should and
the gap between transport investment
between North and South which is because
the government's taking over there's no
guarantee it's going to get any better
a failure to recruit and train drivers
compounded by industrial disputes is at
the heart of transpennines problems
Northern business is desperate for a
solution we need a government that's
going to deliver hs2 that's going to
deliver Northern Powerhouse rail across
the penins at the moment we can't even
deliver the limited number of services
we actually could run between our
Northern cities and it just isn't good
enough
this week we'll end with yet more
strikes across the network affecting
Eurovision among other weekend plans
a good job commuters have learned to be
patient Paul Kelso Sky News in Leeds
the business secretary Kenny badnock has
been on the receiving end of an angry
telling off by the Speaker of the House
of Commons Miss badnot was explaining
why she wrote about the government's
decision not to scrap all e-laws in an
article in the Daily Telegraph before
she presented it to the commons
who do you think is speaking to
Secretary of State I don't want I think
we need to understand each other I am
the defender of this house and these
benches on both sides I am not going to
be spoken to by a Secretary of State who
is absolutely not accepting my ruling
now the former U.S president Donald
Trump made the perception of a threat
from South of the Border a central part
of his appeal to the American public
tonight a restriction on migrants that
he brought in during the pandemic comes
to an end and the now presidential
candidate has said it will be a day of
infamy for those trying to make a new
life in America though it could be a day
of worry Sky's U.S correspondent James
Matthews has sent us this report from El
Paso in Texas
here the sun rises on a crisis every day
or America touches Mexico and is gripped
by an emergency on immigration
this was the day that saw a changing of
the law
the end of the so-called title 42 that
seen a surge in migrants towards the
United States
like this
it was the scene we saw at the border
where El Paso and Texas meets Mexico
these were migrants who'd made it before
the Midnight Hour when title 42 expires
they were among record numbers for
cross-border entries this week over 11
000 in a single day
this was how it looked at San Ysidro
across the border from California
and this was the Mexican Town of Juarez
at Matamoros in Mexico migrants young
and old swam the river that separates
the town from Texas on the last day of
title 42.
America's immigration difficulties are
writ large on the streets of El Paso we
met Wilmer and Yandel from Venezuela
with a 2027 court date for an asylum
hearing the four-year backlog measures a
broken system
what I've pulled out here are the
immigration papers with the court dates
which are set for 2027. the hearing with
the judge is at 8 30. what we need is
bus fare so that we can get to our
destination and begin working
yeah
I want to leave already because look at
the situation we're in we're sleeping on
the floor and eating whatever we can
manage to get a hold of
in a hostel across town there were
disinfecting Camp beds here they
accommodate people with young families
it's America but it's a long way from
Journey's End
for people like Mariela Rivas from
Venezuela
well my journey has been a little tough
because I'm alone with my children and
while I've had scary experiences no one
has helped me on my way over here no one
has tried to help me
the politics of this are as intractable
as the problem itself successive U.S
administrations have struggled with the
immigration issue that is big and
getting bigger it has been a defining
election issue it will be again amidst
the political noise El Paso feels
neglected just think that everybody is
focused on what they want and nobody's
listening and and that's okay but now
it's like let's let's sit down and have
a voice of recent here on the Mexican
mountains across the wall they've
written read the Bible it's the truth on
the U.S side they can't handle the truth
of an immigration system Beyond
efficient control title 42 or not
lasting Solutions remain a distant dream
and James joins us from El Paso tonight
and James we saw of course the human
impact of migration in your report there
but yes again it's also having a huge
political impact in America
yeah a defining issue in elections past
and present because of the sheer weight
of numbers now arriving over the Border
eleven thousand and two consecutive days
that's a record for this particular part
of the border and it matters to more
people to more Americans here in El Paso
migrants who turn up here in Texas are
Boston to cities like New York Chicago
and Denver so it does matter not just on
a human level but also clearly on a
political level that's certainly the way
that Donald Trump wants the situation to
unfold listen to him on American
television last night
we've become a third world nation at
this very moment illegal aliens are
lined up by the tens of thousands ready
to break into our country knowing that
even if they are caught Joe Biden will
order them immediately released into
American communities and many of these
people are very dangerous under Biden
our border is gone our sovereignty is
gone
our national security is gone and we are
quickly becoming that third world nation
that I've been talking about for so long
Donald Trump they are speaking on his
social media platform through social so
not an easy problem clearly for the
politicians trying to handle this
humanitarian crisis certainly not an
easy problem for the human beings and
the very heartless
okay James for now thank you
West Ham have come from behind to take a
2-1 lead in the second leg at their
Europa conference League to semi-final
whether the with a zed alkma the Dutch
side LED at half time but West Ham came
back in the second half to equalize
through a Saeed Ben Rama penalty then
Mikhail Antonio scored a close range
winner 15 minutes from time the second
leg is next Thursday
now move over Elon Musk the Tesla
billionaire may have championed
self-driving cars but kamita is in
Edinburgh will from next week be able to
board a self-driving bus it does have a
supervisor just in case it's needed but
as our Scotland correspondent colleague
Gillis discovered it was a case of look
no hands
it is the nervous moment defying
everything drivers are taught No Hands
on the Wheel the first self-drive bus in
the world
Innovative sensors are doing the job of
humans guiding this nine ton single
Decker through the roads at 50 miles an
hour the initial route over the iconic
fourth road bridge between Fife and
Edinburgh
this is a strange experience usually
you'll be sitting down relaxing not
having to think about anything but you
can't help but look at every twist and
turn this boss is making there are
members of staff on board though a
safety driver sits in the cab monitoring
proceedings while another member of
staff on board looks after the customer
experience
key member of the team as the safety
driver and that's driven by two reasons
so for legislation we need to have a
safety driving account and also where
there's elements of the route that the
technology will hand the control of the
bus back to the driver we must always
have a device is that not defeat the
purpose though uh no because it's the
whole point of the carport project is
about enhancing the technology forces
say there is global interest in this
Scottish product buyers standing by in
Dubai and Tokyo this may be transport
innovation in action but will passengers
come looking to get involved yeah
amazing that's like back to the futurist
I don't know if I would go on that to be
quite honest really yeah why not I just
don't know if I would trust it
technology is so Advanced but you just
never know this glimpse of the future
begins on Monday with pilot Services
carrying the first passengers on this 14
Mile Stretch Connor Gillis Sky News near
Edinburgh